The Five Points District in Denver,
Colorado, has
a legacy of African-American excellence.
Long time business owners
like Franklin and Maedella Stiger
take pride in carrying that torch forward
as the neighborhood changes.
The Frank and Miss Mae
Thank you so much
for allowing me to come in here today.
When people talk about five points,
they always say,
you have to come see the Stigers.
And they've been.
Loving you guys
for the past 40 years, correct?
I've been here for 40 or better.
And I serve the people well.
And so over the past 40 years,
how many people from the community
did you employ here at the Barbershop?
About three off and on,
you know, and during my time.
You had the natural and Jerry curl.
Uh huh.
And that's what brought
the money in.
Miss Mae you had a jerry curl? Yes.
Did you have a Jerry Curl?
And an Afro!
That was my natural. Okay that was your natural.
But then too for the community
with the projects being over in Arapaho,
the little kids would come in
and said, Mr.
Stiger, Can I sweep the floor?
Can I do this? You know for lunch money.
And he used to always have one
or two of them, you know,
come and help clean up the shop
and give them money.
And they would take that money
and then work their school lunch money
for the week.
One of the kids
turned out to be a doctor. Wow.
Whenever he come to Colorado,
he comes to the shop.
I love that.
I just love that you guys are such
a staple in this community
and you're still here.
I'm always looking for ways
to support black businesses,
but the Stigers remind me
that it's not just about buying black.
These small businesses
are the foundation of their communities,
creating the opportunities,
role models and healthy environments
that for so much of American history,
black people couldn't find elsewhere.